Shirou yong-chol now is traveling on the
zoo river in southern benin he's an
ornithologist just like his father he's
come to where there's an especially
large number of birds in this part of
the country much of life takes place on
the water he and his colleague fabian
messier are looking for a particular
species we're going to the place where I
spotted the Anambra wax bill for the
first time four years ago I didn't
expect it here at all but there it was
I was really surprised to see that bird
here my book and it was the right one
but according to the map it shouldn't
even be here it was a really special
feeling for me the two spent four years
collecting money and preparing their
project now there's a lot at stake for
them will they find the bird and if so
how many of them their search begins to
the locals like Lahaul okay ah
the European scientists are exotic I
find it amazing that this white man has
made such a long journey just for a bird
he came from so far away just to see a
bird pretty strange several hours pass
and then there it is the Anambra wax
bill a whole flock in the grass
the night passes the next day Julia and
Fabian have caught 25 birds in their
nets and now they must try to remove
them as carefully as possible I'm
shaking
it's the first time I've had one of
these birds in my hand it's very
emotional catching my first wax bill in
Benin it's an adult wonderful it's tiny
tiny tiny and I picked these red sacks
because they match the red beaks are
these birds from Nigeria where they're
in danger of extinction or are they
native here it's especially important to
measure the beaks then we can compare
them to the beaks of the variety in
Nigeria it often happens that Birds
adapt to their environments and you can
see that in the different beaks or wings
the measurements are important to be
able to make a comparison
what is clear is that this rare and shy
bird does live here and these are the
first moving images of it ever recorded